2024.
THAT'S "THE ANGLE."
JOINING ME NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
PERSONAL ATTORNEY, CHRISTINA,
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
TONIGHT.
YOUR REACTION -- ABSOLUTELY,
YOUR REACTION ABOUT THE
BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT ABOUT THE
SUPPOSE IT NUCLEAR DOCUMENTS
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN AT MAR-A-LAGO
AND WHERE THE CAUSE FOR CONCERN
AND FOR THE URGENCY OF THIS
SEARCH WARRANT IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" TONIGHT.
>> YOU NAILED IT IN YOUR OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
IF THEY HAVE NO GOOD REASON FOR
DOING WHAT THEY DID COME OUT THE
PATHETIC PRESS THAT
MERRICK GARLAND HELD FOR
3 MINUTES WAS INSUFFICIENT SO
THEY HAD TO CREATE FEAR.
NORMALLY THEY'LL COME UP WITH
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED AND WHY
AND EXPLAIN THEMSELVES AND IF IT
WAS A GOOD REASON, THEY WOULD
HAVE SOLID GROUND.
THEY ARE NOT ON SOLID GROUND SO
THEY HAD TO COME UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT WOULD POTENTIALLY
TERRIFY THE AMERICAN PUBLIC INTO
FREELY GIVING UP THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL FREEDOM.
WE ARE ON THE VERGE OF NUCLEAR
WAR OF GIVING UP NUCLEAR CODES
AND MAYBE IT'S ACCEPTABLE THAT
THEY VIOLATED THE PRESIDENT'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO COME UP WITH REASONS
TO MAKE IT SOUND APPROPRIATE AND
MAKE IT SOUND OKAY BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT ACTUALLY HAVE A GOOD
REASON FOR DOING WHAT THEY DID.
>> Laura: JUST SO I'M CLEAR
ABOUT THIS, I WANT TO BE CLEAR,
IS IT YOUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE WERE NOT DOCUMENTS RELATED
TO OUR NUCLEAR CAPABILITIES OR
NUCLEAR ISSUES THAT HAD NATIONAL
SECURITY IMPLICATIONS AND THE
PRESIDENT'S POSSESSION WHEN THE
AGENTS SHOWED UP AT MAR-A-LAGO?
>> THAT'S CORRECT, I DON'T THINK
THEY WERE --
>> Laura: DO KNOW FOR A FACT?
OR HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT IT?
>> I HAVE NOT SPECIFICALLY
SPOKEN TO THE PRESIDENT ABOUT
WHAT NUCLEAR MATERIALS MAY OR
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN IN THERE I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE WERE ANY IN
THEY ARE.
THEY DID A THOROUGH SEARCH AND
WE'VE BEEN VERY COOPERATIVE WITH
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DOJ AND TURNED OVER EVERYTHING
WE FOUND THAT WE HAD.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING AND VERY
GOOD BELIEF BASED ON A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION THAT THERE WAS
NOTHING THERE.
>> Laura: CHRISTINA, WHEN YOU
WERE THERE AND THE AGENTS
ARRIVED, DID YOU HAVE -- ASK
WHAT CAN I ACCOMPANY YOU ON THIS
GRANDEUR AND MAR-A-LAGO?
THEY SAID NO, LIKE HOW DID THAT
PLAY OUT?
>> I DID, AND I ACTUALLY BELIEVE
I COULD'VE JUST FOLLOWED THEM
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE THEIR
APPROPRIATE THING TO DO SO I
STARTED TO FOLLOW THEM AND WAS
TOLD I WASN'T ALLOWED TO.
ON THE PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY ON
SITES AND I KNOW I SHOULD'VE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OBSERVE YOUR
SEARCH.
THEY BASICALLY SAID NO AND I
TRIED TO PUSH A LITTLE BIT BUT
I'M NOT GOING TO PUSH TOO HARD
AGAINST THE FBI.
I BACKED OFF.
AT NO POINT DURING THE RAID
TODAY LET ME FOLLOW THEM OR
ACCOMPANY THEM THROUGHOUT THE
PROPERTY.
>> Laura: CHRISTINA, THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN GIVEN UNTIL
3:00 P.M. TOMORROW TO DECIDE
WHETHER HE WANTS THAT WARRANT
UNVEILED.
WHAT WILL YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
DECISION-MAKING PROCESS AND OF
COURSE THE LEFT IS SAYING IF YOU
WANT TO BE TRANSPARENT.
>> MY RESPONSES PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS GOING TO DO IT WHEN HE'S
GOING AND READY TO DO IT.
HE OWNS THIS COUNTRY AN
EXPLANATION, AND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THAT TOOK
AN EGREGIOUS STEP TO VIOLATE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND INVADE HIS PERSONAL
RESIDENCE.
NOW THEY WANT TO TRY TO SHIRK
THE RESPONSIBILITY BY SAYING WHY
DOESN'T HE RELEASE IT?
NO, THEY OWE US AN EXPLANATION
AND THEY CAN'T GET OUT OF IT
THAT QUICKLY.
I'M SURE PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL
MAKE HIS DECISION AND BASED HIS
DECISION ON WHAT HE BELIEVES IS
BEST FOR THE COUNTRY AND WHAT
WILL BRING US TOGETHER AND UNITE
US.
I'M SURE THAT'S A DRIVING FACTOR
FOR HIS DECISION.
>> Laura: THE SCUTTLEBUTT
BECAUSE IT ALWAYS CHANGES.
YESTERDAY MERRICK GARLAND KNEW
NOTHING ABOUT THE RAID AND THAT
WAS HILARIOUS.
TODAY THEY SENT HIM OUT TO SAY
THAT TRUMP DOES IN EVERYBODY'S
BEING MEAN.
NOW THERE'S A SECRET SERVICE
AGENT PERHAPS THAT'S THE ONE
THAT SAW THE NUCLEAR WHATEVER
MATERIAL AND HE OR SHE IS THE
ONE THAT'S HELPING ESTABLISH
THAT PROBABLE CAUSE FOR THE
WARRANTS.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US TONIGHT
ABOUT THE SECRET SERVICE DETAIL
THAT WAS ASSIGNED TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND CONCERN THAT
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN WHAT GOT THIS
GOING?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IT FOR A
SECOND.
I THINK THE SECRET SERVICE HAS A
LOT OF PROFESSIONALISM AND I
DON'T BELIEVE FOR A MOMENT THAT
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS IS ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR ANYONE IN HIS
CIRCLE.
I THINK IT'S A STORY THAT THE
LEFTIST MEDIA WANTS TO TRY TO
PAINT THE PICTURE THAT SOMEHOW
THERE IS DIVISION WITHIN THE
TRUMP -- THERE'S NOT.
TO THINK THERE'S AN INFORMANT OR
SOME OTHER TYPE OF DIVISION
THAT'S CAUSING THIS, I WILL
BELIEVE IT WHEN I SEE IT AND
I'LL RESERVE THE JUDGMENT.
BUT I THINK SQUARELY IT FALLS ON
THE SHOULDERS OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND I WANT
TO SEE WHAT THEY'VE GOT AND I
DON'T THINK THEY HAVE ENOUGH FOR
FURTHER ACTION.
>> Laura: THEY ARE CERTAINLY
CHANGING THEIR STORY QUITE A BIT
LIKE A 72 HOUR PERIOD.
WHEN THEY WERE IN MAR-A-LAGO,
NOW, YOU KNOW I KNOW THE LAYOUT
OF MAR-A-LAGO-THE MAR-A-LAGO.
DID THEY FOCUS THEIR SEARCH IN
THE PRESIDENT'S PRIVATE
QUARTERS?
IT'S A BIG CLUB, THERE'S A LOT
OF SPACE, OR DID THEY GO ALL
OVER THE ENTIRE CLUB?
THAT'S A LOT OF ROOMS AND THAT'S
A LOT OF GROUND TO COVER AND
THEY HAD 30 AGENTS OR SO I KNOW.
>> THEY WERE TOLD ME THEY ARE
SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT THREE
AREAS, AT THE PRESIDENTIAL
OFFICE, THE RESIDENCE, THE
PRIVATE FAMILY RESIDENCE, AND
THEN THE STORAGE UNITS THAT WE
HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT IN THE
BOTTOM FLOOR.
I BELIEVE THE SEARCH WAS
CONTAINED TO THOSE THREE AREAS
AND I HAVE NO REASON TO BELIEVE
THEY WENT ANYWHERE ELSE, BUT
BECAUSE I DIDN'T ACCOMPANY THEM,
I CAN'T SAY FOR CERTAIN.
I DON'T THINK THEY WENT ANYWHERE
ELSE.
>> Laura: I WANTED PLAY A
MOMENT FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TODAY, WATCH.
>> THE APARTMENT DOES NOT TAKE
SUCH DECISION LIKELY.
IT'S STANDARD PRACTICE TO SEEK
LESS INTRUSIVE MEANS AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE SEARCH AND
ANY SCOPE THAT IS UNDERTAKEN.
>> Laura: IS THERE ANY REASON
THEN LEGALLY WHY HE CAN'T TELL
US -- WHITE RESEARCH BECAME
NECESSARY
>> THAT'S A REALLY NICE SOUND
BITES AND I THINK THAT'S HOW
THEY ARE CAMPAIGNING AND RUNNING
THE ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE WE
WERE COOPERATING WITH THEM, I
WAS THERE WHEN THEY CAME IN
JUNE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HIMSELF MET WITH
THEM BRIEFLY AND SAID HELLO, IS
THERE ANYTHING YOU NEED AND
POINTED TO THE ATTORNEYS AND
ANYTHING YOU NEED AND MAKE SURE
THEY DO IT.
WE'VE BEEN COOPERATING TO THE
FULLEST EXTENT AND FROM THAT
MEETING IN JUNE, THE NEXT THING
I HEARD WAS MONDAY WHERE THEY
SAID YOU'VE GOT TO GET DOWN TO
MAR-A-LAGO, THEIR RATING THE
PLACE.
I THOUGHT THAT'S ODD BECAUSE WE
HAD JUST SAID IF YOU NEED
ANYTHING ELSE, LET US KNOW.
I DON'T BELIEVE HIS STATEMENTS
AND IT SOUNDS VERY NICE AND A
GOOD PRINCIPLE WE SHOULD LIVE BY
BUT THEY DON'T.
>> Laura: MUCH WAS MADE ABOUT
THE SAFE, THE SAFE CRACKER AND
SO FORTH.
DO WE KNOW WAS THERE ANYTHING IN
THE SAFE AND MUCH TO DO ABOUT
NOTHING?
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT IT?
>> I LOVE THE STORY BECAUSE I
ACTUALLY COULDN'T ACCOMPANY THEM
SO I COULDN'T SEE WHAT THEY WERE
OPENING.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE STORIES
BECAUSE OF THE CCTV AND THE
CAMERAS WERE ON.
THOSE IN NEW YORK WATCHING WHERE
AWARE.
I HAVE TO TAKE THEIR WORD FOR IT
AND NONE OF THE PRESIDENT PUT
THE STORY OUT SO I'VE GOT NO
REASON TO BELIEVE IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
I WAS UNABLE TO WITNESS IT
BECAUSE I WAS PRETTY MUCH
RELEGATED TO THE PARKING LOT.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU WERE
SPEAKING WITH THE FBI AGENTS AT
THE TIME, WHERE THEY CORDIAL?
YOU CAN GET A SENSE OF SOMEONE'S
KIND OF EMBARRASSED THAT THEY
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING MORE LIKE
THANK YOU, MOVING ON.
>> INITIALLY, INITIALLY, IT
STARTED OUT A LITTLE HEATED AND
I WAS UPSET AND THEY WERE NOT
EXCITED TO SEE ME.
WE HAD A LITTLE BUT OF AN
INCIDENT INITIALLY ME WANTING
ACCESS TO THE WARRANT THEY
DIDN'T BELIEVE THEY NEEDED TO
SHOW ME THE WARRANTS.
WE THOUGHT ABOUT THAT FOR A A
LITTLE BIT, A MINUTE, NO MORE
THAN TWO.
WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE IT
AND AFTER WE WORKED THROUGH
THAT, IT WAS A LONG DAY.
THERE IS NO POINT IN KEEPING IT
HEATED FOR TOO LONG.
IF ONLY FOR A COUPLE MINUTES
THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT OF
TENSION AND THEN IT CALMS DOWN
FOR THE MOST PART AND EVERYTHING
WAS FINE.
THEY WOULDN'T ALLOW ME INSIDE
ANYWHERE SO I HAD TO STAND IN
THE HEAT FOR EIGHT HOURS OR SO,
MAYBE NINE HOURS AND EVENTUALLY
THEY WERE KIND AND OFFERED ME
WATER BECAUSE I WAS OUT THERE.
I WOULD HAVE APPRECIATED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WAIT AND AIR
CONDITIONING.
>> Laura: DID THEY GIVE YOU
THE INVENTORY LIST BEFORE THEY
LEFT OR WHILE THEY WERE DOING
THE RAID THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
CALL A RAID?
>> WRITES, WE HAVE THE INVENTORY
LIST AS YOU CAN EXPECT IT'S NOT
PARTICULARLY HELPFUL.
SO, YES, I KIND OF HAVE THE
INVENTORY LIST AND THEY GAVE ME
THE OFFICIAL RECEIPTS, --
>> Laura: ARE YOU GOING TO
GIVE IT TO US TONIGHT?
WE ARE HAPPY TO TALK.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO LOVE TO.
>> Laura: WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR JOINING US.
YOU'RE A YOUNG LAWYER AND YOU
WERE PUT IN A -- ONE OF THE MOST
HISTORIC AND EGREGIOUS ABUSES OF
FEDERAL AUTHORITY THAT I'VE SEEN
IN MY LEGAL